hey there and welcome to this ProFlowers
quick tip I'm Cameron and in this quick
video I want to show you a time-saving
hack for After Effects so whenever we
start a new project it always starts out
like this we have a blank canvas and we
typically have to go in and we have to
start creating folders so we can
organize our assets once we start
importing them in so if I go through
here a lot of times I I will create
folders like maybe called an output
folder I'm gonna have a comps folder may
be inside that comms folder or I'm gonna
have additional folders like PCs which I
like to call pre comps that's how I
abbreviate it I also have things like
working comps I'm also going to other
folders like assets and maybe inside of
that one I'm going to put footage maybe
inside a footage I'm gonna put pre
renders maybe also within that I'm gonna
have something for proxies I'm also
gonna have assets for raster images for
vector images the list goes on and on
and on now a lot of times I will import
files and have a big mess and then have
to create this folder structure and
start dragging these files into these
folders but there's a big time-saver we
can do so that we're not to do this
every single time so what you want to do
is you want to create a file structure
something like this you can even create
your first composition so all it's
called this composition output and let's
say that you know for me personally I
like to work at HGTV 1084 or I like to
work at 24 frames a second I like to
have a default duration between 5 and 10
seconds so we'll do 10 seconds black
background I'll click OK so we have a
composition here so let's say this as a
startup template and how do we do that
so all we have to do is we just have to
save our project out to our computer so
when do that really quickly and I've got
it saved out and the neck
important step as I go to my preferences
for After Effects and I go down to this
preference called new project and I
click new project and I have to enable
this box right here and after I enable
it I want to choose my project template
okay so I navigate to where my project
template is that I saved I click it I
say open there it is it's set I'm going
to click OK and then all I have to do
now is just quit after effects and
restart it
now here After Effects is starting back
up and watch what happens as soon as I
click on new project
watch what happens right here I have my
folder structure here already I've got
my output comp already set up here
it's my 1080p 24 frames per second I've
got all my comps set up in here I've got
my assets set up in here and boom I'm
good to go and that's it that's it's a
huge time-saver every time you start up
After Effects you're gonna have a
working folder structure here ready to
go if you enjoy this video I would
invite you to check out pro flows plus
for more videos just like this